wir leben ich glaube das kann man so
sagen in einer ziemlich krassen zeit für
die wissenschaft hunderte wenn nicht
sogar tausende jahre wissenschaftliches
denken haben uns dahin gebracht wo wir
jetzt gerade sind wenn man mal darüber
nachdenkt dann fühlt sich das vielleicht
so an wie ein gerader steiler weg nach
oben oder stimmt nicht vieles hat sich
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern in den weg gestellt wie
wurden die größten hürden gemeistert und
was waren die tricks der
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
um hindernisse zu überwinden wie wurden
theorien zu fakten obwohl sie niemand
glauben wollte genau darum geht es heute
bei doktor watson
the world
und nico -
stay on stage
fri
stell dir vor jemand möchte dass du
beweist dass die erde rund ist okay
heute ist es ziemlich einfach einen flat
öfter schachmatt zu setzen
satelliten gps die internationale
raumstation livestreams aus dem weltall
und tausende stunden hochauflösendes
bildmaterial aber jetzt kommt der haken
ihr befindet euch im antiken
griechenland mehr als 300 jahre vor
christus das heißt anstatt mal eben zu
googeln oder das richtige buch zu lesen
seid ihr in dieser zeit quasi auf euch
alleine gestellt und ohne tausende jahre
wissen sehen wir tatsächlich ganz schön
alt aus darüber haben wir hier auf dem
kanal übrigens auch schon ein
gedankenexperiment gemacht das könnt ihr
euch gerne hier ansehen was macht man
also bevor man dem antiken flat earth
recht gibt richtig man schaut einfach
mal genauer hin und hier zeigt sich was
vielleicht das wichtigste werkzeug ist
um aus neugierde fakten zu machen das
auge
[Musik]
die philosophen im antiken athen haben
quasi hauptberuflich die welt beobachtet
und darüber nachgedacht ohne all die
hilfsmittel die die wissenschaft heute
benutzt und auch wenn es manchmal
galileo galilei zugeschrieben wird war
es aristoteles der so herausgefunden hat
das die erde rund sein muss bei einer
mondfinsternis hat er gesehen dass die
erde einem kreisförmigen schatten auf
den mond wirft außerdem hat er
beobachtet dass schiffe die den hafen in
athen verlassen im horizont zu versinken
scheinen die schlussfolgerung die erde
und die planeten um uns herum sind rund
und das krasse ist diese erkenntnis hat
dazu geführt dass man gerade mal 100
jahre nach aristoteles den erdumfang
berechnen konnte auch komplett ohne
moderne werkzeuge mit der entfernung von
alexandria zur stadt assuan und dem
einfallswinkel der sonne kam ihrer
posten ist in seinen rechnungen auf
40.000 kilometer und das liegt
tatsächlich nur knapp unter dem echten
umfang von 40.000 77 kilometern und das
hat er einfach so ausgerechnet in der
antike leider ist aber vieles von diesem
wissen später verschwunden also nicht
falsch verstehen wir haben das wissen ja
jetzt wieder aber es gab eine zeit da
waren die wichtigen und richtigen
erkenntnisse der alten griechen sagen
wir mal nicht so gern gesehen die rede
ist natürlich vom dunklen mittelalter
[Gelächter]
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
im mittelalter hatten vor allem ein
hindernis die kirche alles was sie
erklären wollten muss der irgendwie mit
der schöpfungsgeschichte der kirche
kompatibel sein und das kann natürlich
den wissenschaftlichen diskurs ziemlich
einseitig machen also haben sie sich
eines tricks bedient es gibt eine
natürliche erklärung für natürliche
phänomene jahr aber irgendwann ganz am
anfang hat gott dieses system ins rollen
gebracht das war so ein bisschen die
idee so sichert man sich ab und kann
gleichzeitig naturphänomen erforschen
und dadurch konnte zum beispiel roger
bacon
wissenschaft machen obwohl er selber
gläubig war wollte er phänomene und
ihrer natürlichen ursachen erforschen im
dunklen mittelalter hat er mathematik
mechanik und sogar astronomie betrieben
aber immer unter dem deckmantel der
göttlichen schöpfung
heute gilt er dadurch als einer der
begründer der wissenschaftlichen methode
und empirie und wir wissen das war
genial und super wichtig aber auch wenn
die kirche ein echtes hindernis für die
wissenschaft war müssen wir an dieser
stelle mal mit einem vorurteil aufräumen
denn so dunkel war das mittelalter
eigentlich gar nicht und nirgendwo wird
das deutlicher als bei den krassen
erfindungen des mittelalters stellt euch
mal die moderne gesellschaft ohne bücher
vor danke an das mittelalter für die
druckerpresse oder denkmal an forschung
ohne universitäten auch hier liebe grüße
gehen raus ans mittelalter besonders zum
ende des mittelalters wurde die kirche
offener für die wissenschaft auch wenn
natürliche anstatt göttliche erklärungen
immer noch kritisch gesehen wurden hat
man zum ende hin sogar die erkenntnisse
der alten griechen an universitäten
gelehrt deswegen stimmt es übrigens auch
nicht dass man das ganze mittelalter
lang dachte dass die erde eine scheibe
wäre das hat aristoteles ja schon mehr
als 1000 jahre vorher widerlegt
mit der zeit gab es immer mehr
erklärungen auf unkonventionelle fragen
und dieser große output der wissenschaft
ist dann in den kommenden jahren
explodiert das heißt aber leider immer
noch nicht dass der wissenschaft nichts
mehr im weg stand die gesellschaft war
zwar offener für wissenschaft aber eben
nicht von jedem oder von je der marie
curie war nicht nur die erste person die
zwei nobelpreise gewannen sie war auch
die erste frau die eine professur an der
berühmten verwandten universität in
paris bekam und all das war zu dieser
zeit überhaupt nicht selbstverständlich
heute ist die welt berühmt für das
beobachten der strahlung von uran
verbindungen aber auch für das wort
radioaktiv damals hatte sie es aber
nicht so leicht vor allem weil sie mit
super vielen vorurteilen zu kämpfen
hatte viele teile ihres lebens wurden in
die öffentlichkeit gezogen und oft hat
man nicht über ihre wirklich krassen
entdeckungen geredet sondern über ihr
liebesleben fast täglich wurde sie in
französischen zeitungen und angegriffen
dort wurde sie als fremde emanze
ausländerinnen und intellektuelle
beleidigt wobei man sich gerade bei dem
letzten wirklich fragen könnte was das
eigentlich für eine beleidigung sein
soll das hat natürlich damit zu tun dass
ihre arbeit für frauen so untypisch war
selbst heute ist die gleichstellung in
der wissenschaft natürlich noch lange
nicht perfekt aber vor allem durch
frauen wie marie curie kann man sehen
was uns die jahre vor ihr alles
entgangen ist heute veröffentlichen
frauen jährlich fast genauso viele
artikel wie männer das heißt wenn wir ab
morgen nur noch wissenschaft von männern
hätten würden uns 50 prozent aller neuen
wissenschaftlichen artikel einfach
fehlen
okay wer man ist kann einem also den
zugang zur wissenschaft schwer machen
manchmal ist es aber nicht nur das auch
neue theorien die gegen den status quo
der wissenschaft gehen können einen
verdammt unbeliebt machen und eine
theorie die wirklich einiges auf den
kopf gestellt hat kommt von niemand
geringerem als albert einstein
wir haben der relativitätstheorie super
viele neue und wichtige erkenntnisse zu
verdanken aber selbst von
nobelpreisträgern wurde ein stein zu
seiner zeit stark kritisiert das problem
astrophysik wäre durch die relativität
angeblich zu abstrakt und mathematisch
man hat sich sorgen gemacht dass die
physik den gesunden menschenverstand
verliert zitat also so ein bisschen nach
dem motto das haben wir schon immer so
gemacht und daran wird sich jetzt auch
nichts mehr ändern natürlich ist so eine
einstellung gift für wissenschaft und
für fortschritt aber das ist nicht das
einzige was sich einstein anhören durfte
journalisten haben den negativen
einfluss von einsteins jüdischen geist
auf die physik kritisiert ein ingenieur
mit ähnlich fragwürdigen ansichten hat
sogar mal eine öffentliche versammlung
gegen die relativität organisiert nach
morddrohungen musste ein stein berlin
1922 verlassen
mittlerweile ist es zumindest hier in
deutschland ist sehr schwer vorstellbar
dass wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler nur wegen ihrer religion
herkunft geschlecht oder ihre
erkenntnisse flüchten müssen heißt das
also dass die wissenschaft über 2000
jahre hindernisse überwunden hat und wer
jetzt am ziel sind haben wir peak
wissenschaft erreicht nun tatsächlich
hat die wissenschaft wahrscheinlich noch
nie so wenig hindernisse gehabt wie
jetzt gerade das erklärt vielleicht auch
den krassen wissenschaftlichen und
technologischen fortschritt des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts noch nie
haben so viele menschen einen
doktortitel bekommen wie in den letzten
jahren und noch vor hundert jahren
hatten die brillantesten menschen der
ganzen welt keine ahnung was zellen sind
und dass die zu ganzen organismen
heranwachsen können also soll sagen
wahrscheinlich hatten wir noch nie so
viel wissen zur verfügung auf dem wir
aufbauen können das heißt aber leider
nicht das alte hindernisse komplett
verschwunden sind oder auch nicht dass
keine neuen hinzukommen peak
wissenschaft haben wir auf jeden fall
noch nicht erreicht diskriminierung ist
leider immer noch ein riesiges thema
wissen und die möglichkeit zu forschen
stehen nicht allen gleich zur verfügung
und das ist schrecklich herkunft
geschlecht einkommen und vieles vieles
mehr bestimmen global aber auch in der
westlichen welt immer noch maßgeblich
den zugang hier sind wir seit marie
curie schon einen langen weg gegangen
aber wir haben auch immer noch einen
langen weg vor uns bis wir am ziel sind
ein weiteres problem ist die
kommerzialisierung von wissenschaft da
gibt es das sprichwort publish or perish
also zu deutsch veröffentliche oder gehe
unter denn der erfolg von studien ist
maßgeblich von verlagen abhängig wenn
man was werden will und von seiner
forschung gut leben möchte dann muss man
in bestimmten journals veröffentlichen
das sind quasi die magazine in dem die
neuesten studien erscheinen damit man
dort veröffentlicht wird muss man aber
geld zahlen und während ein artikel aus
einer ausgabe gerne mal 50 euro im
verkauf kostet verdient die
wissenschaftlerin oder der
wissenschaftler daran keinen cent wie
eine junge wissenschaftlerin dagegen
arbeitet und warum sie deswegen von
geheimdiensten gesucht wird darüber
haben übrigens schon in diesem video
hier gesprochen und wenn man es dann mal
in ein berühmtes journal geschafft hat
muss man am ball bleiben
das ist gut für die quantität von
wissenschaft aber ob davon auch die
qualität profitiert das hinterfragen
gerade viele und damit kommen wir auch
schon zum nächsten punkt forschung an
einer uni ist heute oft sehr viel
schlechter bezahlt als ein job auf dem
arbeitsmarkt frische doktorandinnen und
doktoranden bekommen oft nur schlecht
bezahlte post doc verträge mit ihren
arbeitszeiten und sehr kurzen laufzeiten
so verliert man viele talentierte leute
an die wirtschaft obwohl sie vielleicht
lieber geforscht hätten das ganze ist in
der realität wirklich noch mal viel
komplizierter und komplexer und auch
erschrecken als das was wir hier gerade
anschneiden können falls ihr also mal
bock auf ein extra video zur dunklen
seite der wissenschaft habt dann
schreibt uns das gerne mal in die
kommentare wenn wir genug feedback von
euch bekommen dann können wir dazu gerne
mal was machen aber
das sollte alles eigentlich gar nicht so
pessimistisch klingen ja in zukunft
müssen wir uns über all diese dinge
gedanken machen aber genau deswegen ist
es auch so hilfreich in die
vergangenheit zu schauen so können wir
die gegenwart besser verstehen und für
die zukunft planen und ich finde die
geschichten von aristoteles von marie
curie und von einstein zeigen ganz gut
egal welche umstände
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
machen es möglich deswegen interessiert
mich vor allem von euch ob ihr noch
coole stories habt von
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern die sich gegen große
hindernisse durchgesetzt haben oder
vielleicht sogar daran gescheitert sind
auch das ist interessant schreibt es mir
gerne mal in die kommentare lasst uns
diskutieren
[Musik]
ich finde wenn man darüber spricht was
jetzt gerade der wissenschaft im weg
steht und was sie antreibt dann fallen
vor allem ein paar dinge auf das geld
ist oft zu knapp und die forschung
unterfinanziert dazu kommt der druck in
kürzester zeit ergebnisse zu liefern und
zu veröffentlichen um mitzuhalten
währenddessen werden forschungsprojekte
aber immer komplizierter teams werden
größer und es braucht ein immer größeres
spektrum an experten auch das kann
einfluss auf die produktivität nehmen
aber es gibt auch dinge die jetzt gerade
die forschung besser machen noch nie war
zum beispiel die zusammenarbeit so
einfach wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler können ganz einfach aus
verschiedenen kontinenten miteinander
arbeiten und all diese dinge hat sogar
eine repräsentative studie im auftrag
von merck belegt und hier lohnt es sich
wirklich mal reinzuschauen besonders
krass fand ich dass 73 prozent der
befragten teilnehmer sagen dass der
druck immer mehr zunimmt 59 haben
gleichzeitig sogar gesagt dass darunter
die qualität der forschung leidet und
das ist nur ein ganz kleiner ausschnitt
aus einer sehr ausführlichen und
interessanten studie vielen dank an
merck für die unterstützung bei diesem
video an euch vielen dank fürs zuschauen
und wie immer bleibt neugierig patrick